well of the two movies I've seen in the
last six months or so that were finished
by completely different filmmaker then
started it this one has the seams
showing less solo a Star Wars story so
yeah let's talk about this thing I've
just gotten back it's not a trainwreck
which honestly that alone is better than
had any right to be if you've been
following the behind the scenes stuff at
all and how much of the thing had to be
reshot on top of how questionable an
idea it is in the first place it is
solidly put together it flows well the
key performances work it's fine it's not
bad
I've actually been spending the last
hour or so trying to figure out why this
movie doesn't quite work for me and
there's a few instances here and there
where I can firmly point to issues with
the film itself but I think to a certain
extent there there are outside forces
there's one thing that I'm not entirely
sure like one of my major complaints I
don't know if it was a problem -
screaming I went to I'm gonna be taking
my mother to this again next week so
after that I'll know whether or not this
was this was just a problem with the
screening I had but I feel like the
camera really really really needed to
pull back like about a foot for most of
the movie it felt like everything was a
little too tight initially I found
myself going like his boys this cut
heavy is the shake he can't cuz I'm
having a hard time you know totally
following you know quickly and smoothly
what's going on which is not typical for
Ron Howard he's not known for that and
eventually I realized this because the
camera is in about here when it should
be about here and the result is when
it's this close when stuff's going on
it's much harder to parse out because
you don't have a
for view of the thing again though it
was so consistent across a lot of the
movies I have to wonder if something
went wrong with like the aspect ratio
and the projection booth or something I
don't know but if that is actually how
the movie is that's a big problem or at
least it was for me but the other
problem
the trailers kind of ruined it for me
they showed too much now normally when
people say the trailers show too much
they mean like the trailer blew a major
plot spoiler you know that would be
something like say the trailers for
tomato Genesis and yet that certainly
can recommend and this also might not be
a problem everybody else has but with me
and also before I get into this I didn't
like watch every trailer every TV spot I
watched the teaser trailer basically the
one that they put out at the Super Bowl
and then the full trailer I might have
caught one more after that like I didn't
go out of my way to see it I'm not sure
I fully paid attention to it you like it
would have played in front of a youtube
video or something but with me with
these trailers there's a part of my
brain that has cataloged all of the
locations all of these set pieces that
we see in in the trailer and there's a
part of my brain that basically is going
through the checklist okay we haven't
seen this yet and as a result I kind of
spoiled myself because I think okay well
I know we were in this perilous
situation but I know this this and this
character are gonna survive because
later on we see them in a shot in this
setting and we haven't been there yet or
you know the characters arrive at a
setting and I immediately know all of
there's gonna be an action scene here
because I remember this one shot from
the trailer and that's clearly the same
location I don't want to do that that's
just crap that my brain
does and it did a lot in this movie it
doesn't I was gonna say it doesn't
always happen like it's my default so
the instances in which it doesn't happen
even with films that have shown me
late-game stuff in the trailers our
instances where I'm so wrapped up in the
story and the characters that it
overrides the part of my brain that does
that which was not the case here um in
terms of how bad the amount of stuff
that was in the trailers and how late in
the game agos I think it was two hours
into the movie before I stopped seeing
things that I had seen in the trailer to
some degree or other so yeah marketing
kind of killed my own personal enjoyment
of a movie that I might have enjoyed
more otherwise I think the other maybe
fundamental thing about it is that it's
a little too grim I mean what's great
about Han and in the first Star Wars
especially which this is the one that
comes before that so that's that's the
you know the mold that that he's heading
into he's fun and while he's got a
little bit of swagger a little bit of
attitude in this I would like to think
that a han Solo film would have that air
of fun spread across it like let's let's
show his world and have that world be
fun too but his world isn't fun and I
understand it's like underground and
smugglers and gangsters and all that I
understand that it's dangerous but it
can be dangerous and still be fun this
is too dour it's it's too grim and I
don't mean grim like like everyone
everyone and everything is miserable
it's not it's not a DC Cinematic
Universe movie but it it's missing a
lightness of tone it's missing a sense
of fun that really should have been at
the core of this thing oh and this is
there's one last problem that is kind of
at the core of this this thing which is
that when you do a prequel film for a
character
like Han who is not particularly loyal
who's a little bit amoral who's overly
selfish and who needs to overcome those
things in the films we've already seen
the problem is you can't just have them
stayed the exact same way or at least
you probably shouldn't especially if
you're claiming to do anything close to
an origin story because he needs an arc
and you can't just have him be the same
and have that be an arc so either he has
to be even more amoral and they didn't
go there because they would have had to
made him like a completely unrepentant
and you know murderer
basically to make him worse and have how
we saw him at the start of the first
Star Wars film be an improvement or you
give him a standard hero's journey and
now subtly it doesn't make a heck of a
lot of sense that he is as jaded as he
as he is in in the first Star Wars that
he needs to sort of be pulled kicking
and screaming into being a good guy when
being a good guy seems to be such a
fundamental piece of his makeup in this
film it's even pointed out by other
characters at a few point that he's down
at his heart a good guy and he tries to
be like no I'm I'm not the good guy and
that might have played better if there
had been more emphasis on him like
really idolizing the world that he was
now operating on like honestly if
they've done a narrative like he in his
mind glamorized being an outlaw and that
he thought being bad was the best that
you could do in this world that's an
angle that might have worked they didn't
go for that though they went for him
being basically motivated by a love
interest and trying to protect and help
her so his whole trying to be bad and
tough rings not quite as true and the
fact that he has a heart of gold running
through this means he's actually somehow
regressed by the time we get to Star
Wars and I'm not saying there's no way
that that can happen and I'm sure they
want to make at least one or two sequels
to explain how he how he got there but
you know you need to make a solid movie
that connects and it as far as hot as a
through-line right now it just doesn't
there's another thing that doesn't
connect worth a darn but that's a
spoiler and we'll get there
drilling into it a little bit more let's
talk some of the performances we've got
the guy who plays solo I'm not gonna try
and pronounce his name I'll put it up on
the screen that last name just
intimidates the heck out of me but in
any case he is pretty good he's not
I mean he's not spot-on he doesn't
embarrass himself which would have been
really easy to do I don't envy anyone
who tries to play a role made famous by
Harrison Ford because Harrison Ford has
a quality that is is really just kind of
innate and very few other actors have
which is just an ease he makes it look
easy he makes it look like he's not
trying but not know like I don't care
way not in a you know I'm not I'm not
present way just you don't feel like you
see him acting you feel like you're just
watching him it's just so natural and
easy going and just flows you're just
like I'm just hanging out with a guy
whereas where's the guy playing young
Han Solo you can see that he's acting
not acting badly but it doesn't have
that easygoing freeform flow that
Harrison Ford in the role of Han Solo
has he does thankfully have a have a
good rapport with you Baca that's
important Donald Glover as Lando works
well woody harrelson as Beckett is
perfectly fine Emilia Clarke is she
works her character is not particularly
unique or interesting but she's fine in
the part
dito Paul Bettany I do have him I do
have a character that I didn't like
actively didn't like
and that's l3 and now that's the droid
that's Lando's droid and that that reeks
of trying too hard now I like droids as
a rule I even like some joys that were
very clearly you know a lot of effort
was put to put into finding ways for you
to like them I like r2 I love I love
bb-8 I liked k2 from rogue one l3 I
don't like her and maybe that's the
first thing I tried to think I think I'm
fairly certain that this is the first
droid in the films at least I doubt and
all but like the TV shows or the video
games or what have you but I'm pretty
sure this is the first Road in the film
with a distinctly female tone to its
voice which is fine but it walks with a
hips way like a really exaggerated hips
way and the minute we got a shot that
was pulled back enough for me to get a
good look at what was going on with his
robots hips I'm looking at that going
really really and that kind of soured me
on a character that I was iffy on up to
that point anyway so I did not like l3
really very much at all some of the
other characters that you know there's a
lot of side characters that are decently
done the story plays out about how do
you how you would expect and again
surprises are even lessened if you're
like me in regards to keeping an eye out
for stuff that you already saw on the
trailer alright that's it for spoiler
free there's something I want to say
that isn't like major spoilers but
they're like little things spoilers so
if you don't want that then the last
thing I'll say before getting into that
is just it is not a bad movie and by all
rights it should have been I'm not super
excited about the fact that I'm gonna be
seeing it again because I'm gonna take
my mother to it okay so there's your
spoiler free so getting
two kind of minor detail spoilers
remember in indiana jones' olestra say
during the opening sequence with young
ND we see him go through this whole
thing where he gets the fedora
he holds a whip for the first time we
find out why he hates snakes and he gets
the scar on his chin and it's kind of
silly and goofy and contrived but the
movie gets away with it because it's
light and it's fun and it's over fairly
quickly and it doesn't keep happening
again and again yeah this movie does
that kind of thing for it throughout I'm
not sure it's ever quite as goofy as as
that sequence in Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade is but it is more frequent
and every time I was in the theater yeah
and I felt like the movie was going hey
hey you ever wonder how Hine got the
last name solo you you you ever wonder
why he calls Chewbacca Chewie hmm have
you wondered what the Kessel run is have
you wondered how many other capes Lando
has you want to know where Han got his
blaster you ever wonder if Lando knows
he's Miss browsing his name when he
pronounces it han that kind of stuff is
in there a lot and every single time it
came up I just I wanted to stand up in
my seat and just start singing nobody
cares nobody cares okay I'm about to get
into proper spoilers to talk a little
bit more in terms of specifics oh here
we go so the last stretch of the movie
is actually probably my favorite bit
last I don't know 10 15 minutes or so
because once it exhausted all the stuff
that I'd seen in the trailer I was
genuinely interested with you know the
the plan and the cross and the double
cross that played out really well I knew
eventually that Kara was gonna betray hi
I called that cuz
because she has to I mean either that
had to happen or she was gonna die it
was one or the other but really that
whole stretch at the end I was I was
more engaged than I have been with
anything else because you know up to
that point like I said the the trailers
they just showed too much they showed
the Train job they showed hon you know
in the in the yacht
you know chatting with Kyra so I knew he
was gonna run into her there so that
wasn't a surprise the the Kessel run not
only you know did we know it was gonna
be there but the fact that they
encounter a giant living thing was not a
surprise cuz they children in the
trailers but it was nice during that
last stretch of the movie to be like I
don't know exactly what's gonna happen I
have a feeling I know I was gonna play
out and I was mostly right but I it's
not like I'm waiting for this shots now
has gotta happen now we're about to see
that we haven't seen this yet well in
order to see that thing that was in the
trailer this will have to happen first
oh and there it is I know exactly what
was gonna happen so that stuff wasn't
going on anymore so I was enjoying it
more right up until the reveal at the
very end that literally made me slap my
forehead so Darth Maul is apparently a
crime lord now and I'm not excessively
shocked at the idea that he's not dead I
mean I know economically he was already
alive in in some of the TV shows I can't
remember if he appeared in both clone
war and rebels I didn't really watch
either I've seen like a smattering of
episodes on either one but it's so the
idea that he's alive and with robot legs
I'm like cool fine but the logic doesn't
track from Sith apprentice dedicated to
the destruction of the Jedi to crime
lord
I'm not gonna say you can't get there
but it's not a it's not an odor logical
leap I mean I can't just it's not a safe
assumption that if he hadn't died you
know being cut in half and falling down
that hole that he would rise to the top
of a criminal organization whose goals
do not seem to automatically line up
with what it was he was trying to do
before maybe if you know the the other
material this makes more sense but as
someone who really only watches the
movies I saw that reveal I slapped my
forehead cuz it seemed just stupid and
the more I thought about I'm like okay
there could be a reason but like I can't
I can't connect those dots on my own
that's a huge leap and I can't make it
so that was dumb that was one of the
first not first but few things in the
movie those flat-out stupid but other
than that it's just I think that's
really the only spoiler that's all that
worth getting into I'm sure they plan
sequels and they'll show how much Keira
disheartens him breaks as hard and
that'll be what ultimately makes him
more of the scoundrel like I'm sure
that's the plan and the hope depending
on how this thing does at the box-office
and again it's fine it's fine it works
it's not awful but there isn't a lot
that stood out to me there wasn't a lot
that was like ooh yeah more of that
please
maybe Donald Glover is lando but the
rest of it I'm like this is fine it's
not insulting except the Droid hip
swivel that was in that and the mall
thing that those those are a little
insulting but aside from those like
overall the films are they're not an
embarrassment it's not as good as rogue
one I don't know how to compare it to
something like the last Jedi because the
last Jedi had parts that were amazing
but also parts that were awful and the
last Jedi's hai
are way better than solo but it's those
are also way lower so I don't know
depending on whether you want a roller
coaster or just an even keel of white
noise I think ultimately I I will
probably say last Jedi is better but
that has to do with my own preference
for a flawed movie that's interesting
over a predictable one that's just kinda
there and that's sort of solo it's about
what you'd expect not much more its
competent it's fine
so that's solo a Star Wars story have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments oh let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do like and subscribe and support me on
patreon and follow me on Twitter and
that Deadite that that I thought that
links for all this stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]